abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
Sürmene çamburnu köydeyiz babaannemin
evinde annemler çay tarlasına çay
topluyor Ben de su bekliyorlar
Bir 90 serisi 6 yaşındayım
kucağımda su şişesiyle annemlere doğru
ilerlerken birden siren sesi başlıyor
annemle çabuk makasını Oyna oyna
fırlatıyor doğru ağaçların altına
koşarken Bana diyorlar ki eve gitmek ki
ben eve yakın olduğum halde annemlere
doğru koşmaya başlıyorum kucağımda su
şişesi tam yanlarına varıyorum ki bomba
patlıyor ya
bu gökten taşlar yağıyor ben o anda
o da başardığım için kendimle
ağaçlara da gurur duyuyorum bizi
korudukları için
vaktiyle köyden birisi arazisinde Madem
bulmuş ve zengin olacağız bize gitmiş
hükümete haber vermiş
Çok geçmeden
geldiler arazilerin hepsini kamulaştırdı
lar bizim paramızı da taşlar düştü böyle
büyüdüm
bu ilkokuldayken Şarkıcı olmak
istiyordum
hep zaten assolisti olurdum törenlerde
en sevdiğim dersler resim müzik beden
eğitimi miydi orta okula geçince ressam
ya da
stilist olmaya karar vermiş olsam ben
liseye geçtiğimde Okul hayatım bitti
yi Havva'nın Yasak elmayı dişlemesi
Neyse benim de
ergenliğe geçmem aynı şeydi Dünyam
değişti
ya zaten o zamanlarda kızların
okumasının teknozum görünmüyor nasıl da
kocaya gidecek
Ben de zaten derslerim WhatsApp aklım
fikrim şarkılarda türkülerde
danslarda da annemle zaten o sıralarda
yeğenim doğmuş annemle yengem Tarlada
bahçede çocuğa bakacak biri lazım derken
bu
saçlarım zorla örtüldü
bu kıyafetlerimi kontrolden geçiriyorlar
dışarı çıkmak yok izinsiz bir yere
gitmek yok Konuşmak yok zaten Kızlar çok
konuşma
iş yapmak var
yemek yap evi süpür Çocuğa bak çay topla
fındık ayıklama mi sırayla
ders çalışmayı sevmeyen Ben o kadar çok
özledim ki
o
okula giden arkadaşlarımın kitap
özetleme Ödevlerini ben yapmak istiyorum
ama Böylece
Bu kitapları ne kadar kutsal olduğunu
öğrendim okudukça
bu Elimi kolumu Bağlasalar da
Dünyayı Geziyorum
okul Yolları
Kamburu sahilindeki Evimizin önünden
geçiyorduk zil seslerini duyuyordum
çıkışlarda mavi örnekli öğrencilerle
liseli talebeler renk renk birbirine
giriyordu Ben de böyle Balkon
demirlerine yaslanıp onlara bakar
ağlardım
boyu hiç uzamıyor durdu suratında
yaralar çıkıyordu oldu dişlerin
dökülüyordu kim yolda beni görsen ne
daha bunu yazıyordum
ya da çabuk gideceğim seni kimse almaz
bu pijama yemek yazanı Aslında o
zamanlarda sıfır beden modası
başlamıştık etme olsa birlikte ama
Türkiye daha gelmemiştir bir en küçük
beden 36 belinde
pantolonlarımın içerisini iki kat tayt
giyiyordu yazın bile
bakın böyle olmayacak yanlarından
daraltır boylarından kısalttım derken
Böylece dikiş dikme öğrendim annemin
çocukken böyle arabacılık oynadım
katalım makinesi vardı onu da kendimi
kıyafetler dikmeye başladım bir gün
mahallemizde
ile halk eğitim kursu açıldı kumaş
boyama üzerine hemen ona başladım
Çünkü sanatın herhangi bir dalıyla
uğraştığınız da şöyle bir yanı olduğunu
hatırlarsınız
çocukluğunuzdan
içinde Bulunduğunuz zamanı
bu
fark etmezsiniz
kendinizi uzayda hissedersiniz
etrafınızdaki böyle tanıyı duymazsınız
bir şey koyarsınız ortaya bir değer ve
kabul gördükçe de içinizdeki değersizlik
duygusunu acısını hafif etmiş olursunuz
İŞKUR sacımız
bu yeteneğini keşfedip beni teşvik
etmesiyle ressam olma hayalim yeniden
canlandı kurs sonu sergisine de
yapılan resimlerin çoğu satılınca elimde
para geçti ve çok daha özgürce su
hissettim kendimi gittim Kimseye
sormadan açık liseye yazıldım
güzel sanatlara hazırlık
kursuna başlamam gerektiğinde de kendi
İlkokulu'nun anasınıfında Yardımcı
öğretmen olarak işe başladım gündüz
çocuklar akşam
Rise dersleri ÖSS testleri hafta sonları
Veysel Hoca'nın resim dersleri vız vız
arı arı gibi çalıştım Çalıştım çalıştım
bir
hedefin Mimar Sinan Üniversitesi Çünkü
zannediyorum ki
okulunu bitirenler büyük sanatçı oluyor
Ben de büyük bir sanatçı olmak istiyorum
sonunda sınav zamanı geliyor ama berbat
geçiyor ben böyle
böyle korkunç bir psikoloji ilik
Yalova'ya Ablamın yanına gidiyorum
bekliyorum
umutsuzluk mutsuzluk içinde
bu
kazandığımı öğreniyorum böyle tavuk
çocuk hep birlikte ağlamaya başladı
Benim için o kadar büyük bir hayal ki
Bu okula kayıt olana dek
kendini bir öğrenci olarak
düşünemedim
kayıt günü geldi 23 yaşında üniversiteye
başladım
ön ilk gün Osman Hamdi Bey salonu var
Mimar Sinan'da oradan her yıl mezunların
sergisi olur o sergide Geziyoruz ve ben
o gün şunu anladım
Şu yani Mimar Sinan'dan mezun olmak
büyük bir sanatçı olmama yetmeyecek
zaten gördüm ki ders atölyelerde dedi
ama baskıcı bir hava var o
çok aşırı gelenekçi
negatif bir hava var
Hiç de hayal ettiğin gibi değil
böyle bir zaman geldik resim yapmaktan
sordum
iki sınıfa geçtiğimizde En yakın
arkadaşım Esra
aynı zamanda sınıf arkadaşımdı onunla
birlikte şunu öğrendik ki
iki okul birincilerine tabanca ödülü
veriliyor tam 46'nın anında rakip olduk
sınav sonuçları asıldığında hangimiz
daha yüksek puanı aldı diye koşa koşa
gidiyorduk 3. sınıfta hala tövbesi değil
diğer olduğunu keşfettim Dolayısıyla
orada Gülçin Aksoy olası tanıştığımda
güncel sanat eğitimi aldım Bana göre
okul Hayatım orada başladı Kendini
özgürce ifade edebiliyorum yaptığım
Deniz deneysel çalışmalar
da dikkate alınıyor o zamanlarda evde
biriken naylon poşetlerle kolajlar
yapıyordum ekonomi ve ekoloji üzerine
politik işlerdi ki ilgiyle karşıladılar
sergilendi ler ver koleksiyonlarına
girdiler artık sana gel sanatçı olarak
anılmaya ve
ve kazanmaya da başlamıştım son yılkent
ve sanat etkinliklerine kabul edildi
kabul ediyorum ve Okulu bir dönem
uzatıyorum
proje üretimleri için bir iyi gezerken
Olimpia bel tepesinden çok etkiliyor
Çünkü burası İkinci Dünya Savaşının
kalıntılarından oluşan bir Tepe proje mi
Orada gerçekleştirmek istiyorum Türk
Sanat Müziği formunda bir şarkı yazıp
gösteriyorum türk-alman öğrencilerinden
oluşturduğum Koray'la da hep birlikte
seslendiriyor Uz bu performans stoja
gazetesinin sanat sayfasının kapağı
oluyor Ben O heyecanla geri dön da
hemen gidip de Yolumuz iki derneğine üye
oluyorum toplumsal içerikli yazdığım
şarkılar ya bestelerle Kendi diktiğim
kostümlerle sahneliyor
abone ol
bu ve böylelikle ilkokuldaki şarkıcı
olma hayalimi Çağdaş sanat alanına
taşıyarak gerçekleştirmeye Başlıyorum o
sırada ilginç bir rüya görüyorum
tarihi bir mekandayız arı tepsi tepsi
baklavalar var altın gibi Parlar bir
tane alıyorum Esra'ya taktırıyorum sonra
kendini takıyorum
Buradan bir süre sonra ama Esra okul
birincisi oluyor Okulu uzattığım için de
bir dönem sonra ben okul birincisi olur
mu Sabancı ödülünü ikinizde alıyoruz
3 aynı zamanda yaklaşan ilk kişisel
sergim e hazırlanıyorum o dönemde bütün
zamanında naylon poşetlerle evin içinde
geçiyor
şu içinde anlıyorum ki kariyerinde
yükselmek beni hayatta mutlu eden şey
değil sanki yine biri beni yönetiyor
sanki Yine ben Enes tel eşiyorum
sanki Yine Özgür değil her şey bir yana
yabancı bir ülkeye gittiğinizde kendi
dilinizi Konuşmak isterseniz ya ben de
Karadeniz dilini özlüyorum Hep o dilleri
hep o kültürlü kendini mutlu hayal
ediyorum
içinde olduğum bunalımdan an ancak bir
kararla çıkabildim O da herşeye yeniden
başlamak kendi doğanda ve tek başına
Böylece babaannemin bacısı yeniden
tutmaya başladı
tabi birçok tarihi ev gibi o da epeyce
yıpranmıştı ama umarım ressamlar
yetenekleriyle paralel Bağlar
kurabilirler seheri Ship ustalıkla
başlayabilirler ve
bu
bilmeyiz Zaten bana göre yere resim bal
kurma sanatıdır ben bu düşünce ile 150
yıllık geçmişi olan tarihi evimizi kendi
ellerimle restore ederken
Dokunduğum her şeyle kendi hasar görmüş
ruhumu onarmayı da başarabildim gül
yaşamak hayatını kendin yönetiyor
olmakla birlikte
ruh zihin-beden bütünlüğünü ve
farkındalığı ile hüküm etmeden
yaşamaktır
bir her ne kadar ben ekolojik de hayatla
bunu başarabilmiş olsam da kendi yer
elimde ve dünya genelinde yaşanan
sorunları sahiplenmeden
huzurlu bir hayatı sürdüremeyecek mi çok
iyi anladım
90'lı yılların sonuna doğru
Karadeniz Bakır İşletmeleri
toprağımızda madeni alıp piramitlerle
oyup
mı gitmişti 2000'lerde ise yerine
başkaları geldi trabzon-rize katı
atıklar Birliği
çevre kanunları'nı çiğneyip
Öf vahşi depolama ile oluşan çamburnu
çöp Dağları
ve tüm eylemleri ve açılan davalara
rağmen
15 yıl boyunca durmadan hukuksuzca
yükselmeye devam etti hala ediyor ve
daha bir sürü şey
ya
Ben büyük bir sanatçı olmak için
çıktığım yolda kendi alınyazımı
değiştirdiğim gibi
İyi ki
doğdun toprakların kaderine
değiştirebilmek için ilerliyorum
Şuna eminim ki baş arsamda başaramazsam
da
bu mücadelem Geride bıraktığım en
değerli eserim olacak
orta O bir köy var uzakta
O köy bizim
köyümüzdür
gitmesek
kalma sakta
oker bizim köyümüzdür güm güm güm